et on la version images allait te
regarde
anne parillaud alors c'est vrai on a ça
dans un coin de son salon le regard
d'anne parillaud c'est très agréable
et puis à bien pire c'est vrai ya ce
tiers non à vos vous l'avez tous les
jours qu'une prise une seule prise a dit
qu elle aurait pu prendre un coca avant
un rôle pour la refaire et voilà
mais justement tiens jean-michel
justement il va faire un concert à pékin
le 10 octobre
vous le porterez sapin pékin alors ce
sera le premier concert en cinq ans ça
aussi il est bien entendu
voilà chacun y aura des hauts il y aura
des haubans leurs parents vous concerne
assez différent de ce que j'ai fait
jusqu'à maintenant qui est donc se situe
devant la cité interdite
ouais et avec des écrans qui sont dans
différents endroits de pékin dont le sud
la place tiananmen et donc qui est
diffusé en 5 1 est qui et qui a aussi
ceci de particulier puisqu'il ya
énormément de sociétés françaises qui
soutiennent toute cette année de la
france en chine et notamment thompson et
le aussi bien sur le plan la
scénographie que sur le plan de la
retransmission
la retransmission devait avoir lieu en
haute définition est aussi bien en
direct d'ailleurs en chine ce qui est
une première qu en europe et on aura le
sérieux transmis en chine certains sinon
certaines associations de base sera
déguisé en char place tiananmen c'est
vrai que c'est mon humeur ça s'est pas
gênée par la nature du régime chinois
non moi je suis allé dans les années 80
j'ai été le premier artiste n'est pas la
jouer là bas juste après la chute de la
bande des quatre
je connais bien les milieux
intellectuels et artistiques chinois
depuis
et quand on m'a proposé ce projet je
suis allé je suis allé à pékin pour
justement un petit peu me rendre compte
de l'état des choses et c'est vrai qu'il
ya des choses qui ne vont pas encore
comme on le souhaiterait mais j'ai reçu
le soutien de la totalité des
intellectuels des écrivains comme
d'acide j'ai comme sous signes comme des
musiciens des cinéastes qui ont tous
envie aussi de reprendre un peu la main
dans dans le si on va là-bas et on les
laisse pas isolé c'est ce que vous
faites bien sûr soit on n'y va pas parce
que quand même en chine ya les camps de
concentration quand même bien sûr depuis
le départ est aussi qui attaque le
marché chinois qui est un marché
incroyable
c'est aussi là surtout pour les pirates
n'ont pas créée ni celles qui se vendent
mais les et doit faire là bas aussi
disons disons que oda au delà de ça je
crois qu'effectivement il ya deux
attitudes comme le disait thierry il y
en a une qui consiste à rester chez soi
et à se dire tant que les choses ne sont
pas comme nous on pense qu'elles doivent
peut-être dans un pays en plus que je
rappelle d'un millier près d'un milliard
et demi jean donc les choses sont
forcément un peu différente
et à ce moment là finalement ça change
pas trop les choses qui vous bien se
dire que pour nous pour pour la chine où
on est un peu monaco donc notre opinion
compte pas beaucoup il ya une autre
attitude qui consiste à aller là bas
et puis à aa a communiqué à rester quand
même attentif à ne pas non plus se
laisser aveugler par un certain nombre
de choses et je crois que c'est le but
de l'année de la france en chine est
convaincue
non pas trop mais il y avait quand même
beaucoup de gens ici et je pense que
c'est bien d'aller dans un pays et de ne
pas attendre que les choses changent
pour pour y aller et c'est bien si on
veut un peu noyauter le pays et puis et
puis quitte à faire des esclandres ou
désactivant diplomatique mais de
profiter du fait d'être là bas pour dire
à voix haute
on n'a pas le droit de dire là bas oui
mais ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est que
par les armes et non mais ça ils s'en
foutent dire que le pignon de la france
franchement ça compte ça compte
malheureusement pas beaucoup je pense
que l'union des artistes est très très
important je pense que justement il faut
y aller pour pouvoir l'exprimer pour
pouvoir justement été aussi l'expérience
que les artistes chinois puissent
s'exprimer que c'est aussi ça le
problème et je pense que il faut faire
attention de ne pas être de ne pas voir
un rapport avec les chinois décalé c'est
qu'on a on a certainement été maoïste
aussi au moment où mao des porteurs des
millions de gens donc il faut faire
attention de ne pas toujours avoir une
idée
depuis l'idée préconçue de la chine
depuis café de flore je pense que c'est
important d'y aller et puis de rester
les yeux ouverts de ne pas être naïf et
d'être attentifs vous partez avec votre
maman
on va fêter ses 90 ans avec car tu le
crois ça c'est une contrepétrie elle
risque d'ouvrir sa gueule parce qu'elle
sait quelqu'un qui roule sagal pendant
la guerre elle était dans l'est les
francs-tireurs la région de lyon était
dans les camps donc elle sait de quoi on
suit a été déportée à ravensbrück lc 2
comparé l'aller quand elle en a les a
connues elles tout à fait
donc je suis très très fier très heureux
qu'elle puisse venir et qu'on puisse
justement fêter son anniversaire à pékin
alors je lisais récemment dans la presse
par litre votre père maurice jarre et
vous disiez que ça allait pas mieux
finalement quarante ans après un moment
c'est aller un peu mieux parce qu'il
s'intéressait à votre fils
mais quand même j'ai pas trop envie de
parler de ça parce que finalement les
choses les choses se passent pas si mal
que ça c'est vrai que quand on quand on
vit très loin d'un d'un des parents est
finalement l'absence ou la béance est
pire que le conflit est que quand on se
dit que finalement c'était pas mal qu on
regrettera son père vous n'êtes pas mis
sa main sur la gueule passer au moins
c'est un c'est un vrai c'est un vrai
contact au moins je m'éteins et que
quand ça pas lieu c'est vrai que c'est
assez lourd à porter mais finalement les
choses s'arrangent et puis je pense que
elles vont elles vont s'armer en face en
tout cas c'est ce que je dis c'est un
truc dont vous êtes parmi sa basse et
très difficile parce que finalement
quand quentin finalement si vous avez un
parent un des parents ce que je ne
souhaite évidemment personne mais qui
meurt ouais vous en fait le deuil
l'absence c'est un peu la différence
donc et on n'a pas tellement de manières
de prendre ça enfin moi j'ai eu du mal
mais en fait en même temps je n'en veux
pas c'est l'histoire des parents au bout
d'un moment je ne juge pas
on juge pas son père ou sa mère s'est
d'ailleurs c'est d'ailleurs ce qui s'est
d'ailleurs l'erreur qu'on fait on
choisit pas ses parents choisit pas sa
famille
non c'est vrai maxime le forestier c'est
pas sûr
pas sûr qu'on soit 10 alors jean michel
jarre isabelle adjani a fait de vous
donc on disait tout à l'heure
l'étendard de l'infidélité en fait c'est
assez fidèle aux parements est ce que
j'ai toujours pas compris parce que vous
êtes pressé g 20 ans avec charlotte
rampling et ce qui n'était pas
d'ailleurs un record ce qui était
extrêmement agréable et c'est pas passé
loin quand même
oui c'est long et puis surtout vous êtes
resté trente ans dans l'autre ancienne
maison de disques dreyfus avant warner
qui est votre nouvelle maison disent
donc j'avais quand même des longues
périodes quoi puis donc c'est pour ça
que je me sens absolument pas concernée
par way par cette histoire de partie par
cette histoire de toute façon mais bon
jeu